-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now we're gonna
get to the news.
Russian President Vladimir Putin
is reportedly
expected to formally declare war
this week on Ukraine.
Really? Now?!
Putin's like the guy who's been
dating the same woman
for six months
but refuses to say "girlfriend."
Ukraine has its own dresser
drawer in your apartment.
You're at war.
President Biden, last week,
named Karine Jean-Pierre
as the next White House
press secretary,
which makes her
the first Black woman
and openly gay person
to hold the position.
So she's going to spend a lot of
time at the podium saying,
"No, I mean,
questions about world events."
The Biden administration issued
a warning over the weekend
that the country
may see 100 million
coronavirus infections
this fall and winter unless
we, as a nation,
commit to going out
and catching it
this summer instead.
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell
said, in a new interview,
that the Supreme Court
overturning Roe vs. Wade
could pave the way for
a national ban on abortion.
On the bright side, Mexico might
finally pay for a wall.
At a rally held by
former president Trump
last week, Pennsylvania
Republican Senate candidate
Dr. Mehmet Oz was
repeatedly booed by the crowd.
In his defense, that's just how
Pennsylvania says hello.
The CDC announced
over the weekend
that it's investigating
a recent coronavirus outbreak
on a Carnival Cruise ship.
That might be the shortest
investigation ever conducted.
"It's a cruise ship, you say?
Well, I think we've
figured out your problem."
U2's Bono and The Edge held a
surprise concert yesterday
at a subway station in Ukraine.
If you're curious how it went,
check your iTunes.
It's already in there.
They probably didn't think
that decision
would have such a long tail.
Is that a decade --
Is that a decade ago now?
[ Irish accent ] What's the
worst that could happen?
They're still making jokes
about it 10 years from now?"
[ Normal voice ]
What a good Bono!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good Bono.
I feel like you
rolled your eyes at me, Wally.
And, finally,
a family in Massachusetts
recently rescued a puppy
that they found on
the side of the road, which was
actually a baby coyote.
Said the family,
"I guess it's for the best.
It didn't get along with
our cat anyway."
Thanks to the family
who posed for that photo.
That was the monologue,
everybody.